[Musique]
un garage vient de s'ouvrir à paris ou
abandonner toutes portes closes les
voitures deviennent la proie des
commandes électroniques un chariot vient
saisir ma voiture par les roues arrière
et l'entraînent vers le monde chat
[Musique]
la machinerie va alors la diriger vers
l'un des douze étages de l'auto silo car
tel est le nom du premier garage
automatique de paris la voiture sera
amené devant le box vide pour y être
déposés sans que personne soit intervenu
autrement qu'en vrai sens un bouton
[Musique]
moins d'une minute aura suffi à
l'opération moins d'une minute suffira à
l'opération inverse qui rendra la
voiture à son propriétaire
[Musique]
un appel de phare
et les cales s'abaisseront d'elle-même
une solution moderne au problème du
parti
[Musique]